what about opposite sex friends why is
it that women would want non-kin
non-partner male
compatriots
I've seen suggest that what we might be
doing when we form opposite sex friends
is basically recruiting kind of like
backup mates and so
um that
basically the preferences that we
espouse for our opposite sex friends
look pretty similar to our preferences
for mates and so it suggests we might be
cultivating you know backup mates and
there are some data that people do this
explicitly and you know they'll report
being distressed if they're backup mate
forms a relationship and so some people
do this consciously my guess is a lot of
people might be doing it non-consciously
but still espousing similar preferences
um it's possible also that maybe same or
excuse me opposite sex friends might
have served as protection perhaps if
you're were really aggressive so we
might also be looking for those
especially if you're Patra local right
because one of the ways that a cost
inflicting mate who is doing more mate
guarding would you typically behave is
that they would isolate their partner
their female partner from uh brother's
father's grandfathers Etc and if you've
already been displaced geographically
from wherever it is you're pretty much
on your own and especially when it comes
to physical vulnerability I suppose that
having a male friend around to do that
but it also explains given the fact that
you've had to really scrape the bottom
of the barrel to find a reason that
isn't to do with mating for women to
have male friends I think that explains
one of the reasons why men get so
uncomfortable when their partner their
female partner talks about that male
friend that they've got at work and this
is what I learned from David buss's Men
Behaving Badly the failure of cross-sex
mind reading the male over perception
and the female underperception bias of
attraction that you have this situation
where women and men basically exist in
different worlds when it comes to
perceiving what's going on and this
failure of ability to work out to model
the other person's World very much can
cause two people both acting in a true
way acting in a fair and loyal way to
see completely different situations and
to actually have an awful lot of
friction in their relationship
and I mean even just the integration of
male and female spheres is probably
pretty recent you know so probably
throughout much of human history women
were spending a lot of time with other
women and men were spending a lot of
time with other men you see this in
children you know we segregate really
early and so
the concept of working with all these
opposite sex peers is probably pretty a
pretty novel Challenge and so it would
make sense that it would cause a lot of
friction if we haven't you know
encountered it much through human
history that now it's like we just need
to adjust to these new conditions do you
remember when Peterson said on an
interview
we don't know if this experiment of men
and women working together in the
workplace has worked out or not you
remember when he said this it was about
three or four years ago he got slammed
he got absolutely destroyed for it and
maybe it needed more context or caveats
or maybe it's just the fact that he's a
lightning rod for the culture war and
anything that he says kind of gets taken
as like this is the new headline and we
can go after him about like enforced
monogamy or whatever but
um that's a genuinely interesting
question and it also I've been on this
thing for a little while that
the current framing around uh men and
women and their relationships is very
adversarial right it's super adversarial
that men and women are competing with
each other for
something I don't know what it is
resources or or positions within
companies or status or victimhood uh
position or whatever it is right
men and women for almost all of history
kind of really didn't give a about
each other men were off with their men
doing their main thing and women are off
with their women doing the woman thing
and they would come together they would
have sex the man would contribute a bit
here and there but for the most part
we're in different worlds and this is
one of the reasons that I've been really
trying to drive home this intersexual
competition point because I think it is
a really lovely antidote to this
adversarial world where men and women
don't have the language or the mental
models to be able to understand how to
compete with each other or why they
should compete with each other and they
feel like they're on different teams but
they kind of really don't have any
ground to be able to do it and it causes
people to concept creep and just
randomly create problems out of nowhere
in an attempt to justify post-hoc
rationalize this reason for some sort of
discontent
but when you realize that almost all
competition between women is with other
women and almost all competition from
men is with other men I know it gives me
a little bit more breathing room and it
also means that I know right okay this
is the rules of the game are better
defined I understand how to compete with
men I don't understand how to compete
with women and I don't feel like I do
and yet I'm being told that I am and
yeah I think the intersexual competition
thing in my opinion is going to be a
very important area of research
um to publicize to like really really
get out there because it's this
beautiful
um calming balm antidote to kind of the
cultural milieu that we've seen at the
moment
I I totally agree and the argument that
now we're portrayed as you know men and
women are portrayed as antagonistic I
think it's true and I I have some data
with some some colleagues
um my colleague Carl Aquino
um and Simon uh and so what we find is
this
when you when people encounter
um sexual harassment policies that are
really strict and so basically these
narratives that sexual harassment is
widespread and the consequences are
really steep so the the risks of an
accusation are very high what we find is
that corrodes opposite sex benevolence
so people are less willing to work with
opposite sex peers they feel less
benevolence towards opposite sex peers
they have less motivation to engage in
romantic and sexual relationships with
them and we even did this study where we
asked them how much do you want to
donate to prevent the suicides of
opposite sex individuals and they
donated less and so what I think is
going on is that we keep talking about
all the ways by which men and women
could have antagonistic Relationships by
focusing so much on sexual sexual
harassment and sexual harassment is a
problem but when we emphasize it we are
creating this stereotype of men as
sexual perpetrators and women as ready
to Levy an allegation at any Behavior
perceived as sexual and so it's creating
this you know the antagonism it's
describing
who's Marina gertzberg do you know her
oh I I think I might have found one of
her papers so this is from my newsletter
a little while ago uh hashtag metoo has
hurt women's careers women's
productivity fell post me too largely
due to fewer collaborations with men a
study of research collaborations
involving Junior female academic
economists showed that they started
fewer new research projects after me too
the decline is driven largely by fewer
collaborations with new male co-authors
at the same institution the drop in
collaborations is concentrated in
universities where the perceived risk of
sexual harassment accusations for men is
high that is when both sexual harassment
policies are more ambiguous exposing men
to a larger variety of claims and the
number of public sexual harassment
incidents is high the results suggest
that metoo is associated with an
increased cost of collaboration that
disadvantaged the career opportunities
of women metoo was important to raise
awareness but the intent was not to
impose costs on women's careers
totally yeah I think I
I guess showing that people
um are less like so women don't want to
be mentored by a senior male and that
senior males don't want to they're less
willing to Mentor Junior women they're
less willing to hire attractive women
they don't want to hold one-on-one
meetings with women and so that's isn't
that strange that that's that's men
right that's male mentors
do you meant that yeah but so it was
both the ways yeah yeah but the point
being that we're about to get onto it
women also don't like attractive women
if men are fearful now in a post-metu
world of collaborating with women
especially attractive women and women
had a genetic biological predisposition
going back tens of thousands of years of
not liking attractive women
it's a pretty bad situation
yeah yeah yeah it's not great it's so
it's creating the very thing we'd like
to prevent you know that this hyper
focus on everything that could go wrong
is creating less mentorship for women if
we want to enhance women's you know
career advancement then I think we just
we need to have a more nuanced approach
of kind of what are the negative
externalities of focusing so heavily on
these problems which do it's tough
because they do want attention but it's
worth considering how our attention has
also created problems the problem that
you have is there is a current Trend I
think reinforced by the reward of
inflammatory Language online that
overcooking or over egging over
emphasizing any issue that as yet hasn't
been fixed is uh allowed because we will
get there quicker right if there is one
sexual harassment that is one too many
that means that we need to continue to
hammer the sexual harassment thing and
if we overblow some of the claims or if
we make it more aggressive then it needs
to be that doesn't matter because when
you compare
using words that are slightly more
inflammatory to somebody being sexually
harassed they do indeed Palin's
insignificance the problem is that you
don't get to see these much more below
the surface longer term externalities
that come about by doing this by
overblowing these sorts of topics what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]